great researchers of the past and of the
present are always characterized by one
common thing which is they've asked the
right question see far is a
canadian-based global research
organization that links canada's and the
world's best investigators to address
important questions when you do that
when really smart people productive
researchers come together in a very
interdisciplinary way you not only
create new knowledge you not only
advance the field but you have huge
impact on the world today 2013 the
challenges facing the world are so
complex and so our response to that has
been to launch after a long discussion
after I came on as president of what
we're now calling see far 2.0 and so
extending our global reach being open
and collaborative partnering with others
the importance of young people the
global call for ideas we're really
calling on canada and the world's best
researchers to come forward with great
ideas that work in a.c farm model we're
looking for importance of the question
the quality of the individuals the
quality of the leadership to transcend
discipline that transcend geography to
be problem-based and be of importance to
advancing knowledge important knowledge
and be of importance to the world
you